[Música]
Bienvenidos a la crónica de medio
ambiente de frac24 transmitida desde
charmershaker en Egipto donde se realiza
la cop 27 la Cumbre climática de la ONU
y aquí la discusión de las pérdidas y
los daños ha sido la gran protagonista
especialmente la creación de un
mecanismo para que los países que más
han contaminado y que son los más
industrializados
otorguen dinero a los países más
vulnerables para eso nos acompaña maiza
rojas Ella es la ministra de medio
ambiente de chile y además quien lidera
la mesa de trabajo de pérdidas y daños
en la cop 27 junto a la enviada
climática de Alemania Jennifer Morgan
ministra Gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en France 24 y como decía la gran
discusión ha sido pérdidas y daños Esto
es lo que piden los países en desarrollo
sin embargo las naciones más
industrializadas han mostrado una
reticencia desde Cumbres climáticas
anteriores para crear un mecanismo de
financiación de hecho Estados Unidos y
la Unión Europea fueron los que
hundieron esta posibilidad en la copa 26
en Glasgow A qué se debe esta reticencia
bueno el tema de pérdidas y daños nos
referimos claramente a
las pérdidas y los daños Los costos
económicos que tienen y que van más allá
de las capacidades de adaptación
Dado que los impactos del cambio
climático ya lo estamos viviendo hoy y
son cuantiosos y son recurrentes
conversar de este tema es absolutamente
crucial y yo creo que aquí yo quisiera
primero que nada decir de que
los países desarrollados han mostrado
por lo menos que se van a saltar a la
mesa tenemos un ítem Tejiendo eso es muy
importante se van a sentar a la mesa y
están Han reconocido las brechas que
existen en el financiamiento y yo espero
que con esas dos disposiciones podamos
avanzar durante lo que queda de esta
copa para comenzar a dibujar cómo vamos
a financiar las pérdidas y los daños que
están los países más vulnerables
sufriendo hoy en día bueno pero esta
conversación puede no ser nada fácil y
es que por ejemplo en 2019 en la cop 25
se creó a petición precisamente de los
países en desarrollo lo que se llama la
red de Santiago para pérdidas y daños
que básicamente La idea es conectar
estas naciones menos industrializadas
con un conocimiento técnico para
enfrentar las pérdidas y los daños sin
embargo tan solo hasta el año pasado en
la copa 26 se trazaron los objetivos de
la red y se espera que en esta con 27 se
avance para poner por fin andar esta red
la dificultad que ha implicado que esta
red actúe que puede hablar y qué puede
decirnos frente a la creación de un
mecanismo de financiación Así es yo creo
que hay que entender que en en torno a
la convención marco de cambio climático
las decisiones se toman por consenso
verdad los casi 200 países que son parte
de la convención todos tienen que estar
de acuerdo sobre todas las decisiones
que aquí ocurra eso hace que las que los
caminos sean lentos
pero el consenso tiene que tiene que
realizarse entonces
aprendiendo de que el consenso es un
proceso que Mora que cuesta hay que
encontrar maneras que sean innovadoras
para el financiamiento nunca dejar de
lado el multilateralismo avanzamos
aunque sea lento por ese camino Pero
además reconocer una cantidad de otras
opciones que tenemos por fuera también y
juntando estos dos aspectos Yo espero
que podamos hacernos cargo de la
urgencia y de que no tenemos muchos años
más para
avanzar enfrentar el cambio climático
incluye las pérdidas y los daños usted
precisamente habla de la urgencia de
actuar y es que no solo como política lo
dice sino también justo es
históricamente ha sido una científica
una experta en clima y autora del quinto
informe del panel intergubernamental de
cambio climático que son los expertos de
la ONU desde entonces usted está
diciendo hay una ventana que cada vez La
tierra más para la acción climática a
propósito de esto que pueden hacer los
países latinoamericanos para combatir
Este cambio climático muy importante
efectivamente la ventana se nos cierra
cada vez más más rápidamente y es muy
urgente actuar yo creo que nosotros como
países en desarrollo vulnerables al
cambio climático tenemos que entender
que está en nuestra
mejor interés el subirnos a un
desarrollo verde a un desarrollo en la
cual nosotros rápidamente hagamos
nuestra transición energética lo más
rápido posible porque los países que
piensan que tienen más tiempo para
ponerse al día para estar en en la
frontera de la transición energética yo
creo que van a vamos a nos estaríamos
como
autoinfligiendo
el subdesarrollo para siempre aquí hay
que hacer proactivo y con la ayuda de
los países desarrollados acelerar
nuestros propios procesos de
capacitación de transición energética y
de creación de resiliencia y usted habla
de un desarrollo verde y anteriormente
decía que el desarrollo económico no va
en contravía de la sostenibilidad Pero
cómo lograr este desarrollo verde en una
región que depende de las economías
extractivistas como América Latina y que
se evidencia por ejemplo con la minería
de chile o el petróleo de países como
Venezuela y Colombia
es que en el fondo cuando hablamos de
acción climática
estamos hablando de cambiar el modelo de
desarrollo el calentamiento global No es
otra cosa que un síntoma de
150 200 años de una manera de
desarrollarnos que nos ha dejado con un
planeta en destrucción con un planeta
con calentamiento global con pérdida de
biodiversidad entonces acá No hay ni
balas de plata ni hay soluciones simples
sino que son
cambios muy estructurales y hay que
pensar de que el desarrollo verde y el
desarrollo sostenible son la única vía y
se puede decir que Chile ya va camino en
ese desarrollo verde teniendo en cuenta
la ley marco de cambio climático que
ratificaron precisamente este año y que
le apunta a que chile alcance la
neutralidad de carbono a 2050 Así es yo
espero que con la ley iba a ser una
herramienta muy importante y una ley que
hace nuestros compromisos
internacionales vinculantes de manera
nacional pero también un alto nivel de
consenso en el país de que la transición
energética el desarrollo de la energía
renovable Es una transición que es
beneficiosa para el país tanto
ambientalmente como socialmente como
económicamente también eso obviamente
ayuda bastante a que las cosas ocurran
cuando económicamente esto se hace
viable
pero es una primera pieza lo que ahora
corresponde es implementar la ley y la
implementación de la ley significa que
esto deja ser una agenda de medio
ambiente sino que es una agenda
transversal en el estado completo y
además de generación de capacidades en
las regiones en las comunas de chile y
ese ese es un desafío muy grande en el
cual vamos a estar
en los próximos años de cómo hacemos
realidad como implementamos esta ley y
cómo hacer la realidad en medio de
dificultades climáticas tan grandes que
enfrenta chile que está atravesando por
una sequía desde hace más de 10 años que
incluso ha puesto a la capital Santiago
y a varias regiones en escasez de agua
como asegurar esta gobernanza del agua
efectivamente en el caso de chile uno
uno de los impactos más severos del
cambio climático es una reducción en las
lluvias llevamos ya está terminando el
año 2022 van a ser 14 años con
precipitaciones muy por debajo
del del promedio climático climático y
vemos hacia el futuro que esa situación
se va Lamentablemente a mantener
Entonces tenemos menos agua Pero el
mayor problema que tiene chile es que no
tenemos una manera efectiva de gobernar
el agua gobernanza
Cómo tomamos las decisiones con respecto
a agua y ahí había una había una
reticencia por muchos años y yo espero
que antes la evidencia
de la urgencia de tomar decisiones de
que la sequía le está empezando a llegar
a la Ciudad de Santiago de que nos
pongamos todos de acuerdo y cambiemos la
manera en que tomamos las decisiones con
respecto al agua Durante este año
todavía vamos a instalar algo que
llamamos consejos de Cuenca una manera
de gobernar de tomar decisiones en las
cuencas que son la el territorio
específico donde está el agua y que esto
se pueda transformar en un proyecto de
ley y tener una una gobernanza Nacional
del Agua también prontamente ese eso eso
es absolutamente crítico y le quiero
preguntar la ONU habla de tres crisis la
crisis del cambio climático la crisis de
la contaminación y una crisis de la
pérdida de biodiversidad usted ha dicho
que la solución es unir estas tres cómo
lo está haciendo chile y cómo lo podría
hacer América Latina muy brevemente Yo
creo que es muy importante efectivamente
que miremos estas tres tristes en
conjunto Yo diría que especialmente
especialmente la de cambio climático y
la de pérdida de biodiversidad porque si
no podríamos estar cometiendo el error
de implementar ciertas soluciones que
pueden ayudar a la crisis de cambio
climático empeorando otra crisis y eso
definitivamente no lo queremos por lo
tanto es importante mirar las tres
crisis de manera integral y ser
coherente ser coherente con que no vamos
a
imponer implementar o soluciones que
empeoren nuestra pérdida de
biodiversidad porque es la piel la
biodiversidad finalmente la que sustenta
la vida y todas las actividades humanas
sí ministraba Marisa rojas gracias por
estar con nosotros Encantada
así llegamos al final de La Crónica de
medio ambiente ustedes sigan conectados
con nosotros